tacos because you're not taking your car
anywhere you've been drinking and
hitting the thing all day you should be
determined now fine oh no no i know
you're fine i know you're fine but
listen you've been such a good friend to
me through this whole divorce i would be
sleeping on the street somewhere if it
wasn't for you so please the least i can
do i'm happy to take your car go pick up
some grub okay and i'll come right back
okay you can stay
as long as you need i might take you up
on that okay
dude i'm so sorry something just
happened
what
okay so
i'm in the driveway and i can't really
see anything and i'm in a hurry to leave
and um
and coco was in the driveway
if coco okay yeah yeah he's okay when i
say he's okay i mean he doesn't have any
pain
he's dead he's at peace
what the [ __ ] you killed coco dylan i am
so sorry oh my god go go dude it was
such a it was an accident get the [ __ ]
out of here all my stuff is here man i
don't have any where i can go listen to
me i'll [ __ ] kill you get the [ __ ]
out of here
oh my god
hey man i just came to get my things
where were you
well i thought you told me did i i
[ __ ] up
last night i got drunk and put the black
down and i guess i decided to drive and
i i i
yeah i'm a piece of [ __ ] it's okay oh my
god i don't believe it's okay
don't be so hard on yourself you don't
deserve that
what i did was
unforgivable listen you're gonna get
through this we're gonna get through
this together
he needs a proper burial yeah yeah
thanks man
oh god would have been here sooner i
just thought i was letting you process
you know what i mean yeah
what
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
you